okay so
welcome everybody uh we're going to be
doing a webinar today
on negotiation tips tricks and
strategies
uh i like doing uh
webinars where people participate and so
some of this is actually set up as i'm
going to be
sharing with you ways to even speak
meaning
ways to strategize having a meeting
about negotiation
not just what should be on the table but
but also
um words to use that will
help you position yourself well um
i am happy for you to unmute yourself
and for you to participate
and for you to interrupt and whatever it
is
um so we will have a chance for
questions at the end however
just know that i'm open to that so my
name is andrea mia
first of all um if everybody could just
let me know
that you can hear me okay or raise your
hand if
uh you can't hear me or you can't see
the presentation
just to let me know so i'm assuming
everybody can oh here's the chat i'm
sorry yes we can okay great
fantastic oh aladdin
welcome okay just talk to you a little
earlier anyway my name is andrea mia i
am a
coach i live in portland oregon i've
worked for udacity
for over a year now
and uh i have a very eclectic
background i would say and the thing
that unites it is that
i've been working on storytelling pretty
much all my life whether as a teacher
or working in hollywood or um being a
coach
helping people tell their stories that
that's been
a lot of my my
background negotiation wise
um i have spent
i don't know i guess it was you know
i would say a good portion of my life
having to deal with negotiation
uh in the sense of either negotiating
deals with people
uh negotiating my own salary negotiating
with people
their salaries um and
so i have perspective on negotiation
from a lot of different
different ways of looking at it and one
of the things that
i think is um i'm going to click to this
to talk about where we're going with
this
i put a tip in the um
in udacity has a a a little form that
you can ask questions to
and stuff and we put tips in every now
and then and the first tip that i put in
uh last week was about you should always
negotiate
and somebody and i put that tip in
because
i wanted to provoke people and i
provoked people and
they were like wait a second that's a
cultural thing you know you shouldn't
always negotiate
i think that uh the reason why i put
that in
and the reason why i wanted to do this
seminar
is i want people to have a better sense
of what they are
empowered to ask for
and that they are empowered not to
accept
the first thing that comes out of
someone's mouth as an
offering basically and how to prepare
yourself how to
um prepare yourself for that
conversation
whether it be around a promotion or
whether it be around taking a job for
the first time
um so the answer to do you always need
to negotiate no not necessarily
but um i think that you should
look at taking on
a job look at this this situation unless
they say
absolutely no negotiation we've we've
said
you know from the get go we've said it's
a ten dollar an hour job
and x sec and that that's it that's all
we have
then you know it may not be worth
negotiating in that sense
but you know honestly in almost all
other circumstance unless they make it
totally clear there's absolutely no
wiggle room here
this is what we've got please don't talk
to me
if that is not what they have said then
just know that there is some expectation
that you will negotiate and if you
don't negotiate that that's potentially
a strike not in your favor depending on
what the job is also
and so you know i say always negotiate
i think it's it's about the circumstance
basically but if there is a possibility
that this is something that you need to
consider
um one of the things that i wrote here
in the agenda is you know
what is your value add in pre-framing
which i i
do want to talk about
but the things that we're going to go
over today is creating a negotiation
agenda
research that you need to do in advance
what are things that you can put on the
table to negotiate
we'll talk about those and i hope you
all will share ones that you've thought
of yourself as well
um winning strategy and negotiating a
salary and then we'll have a question
and answers
area as well um so
but i want to talk about this framework
thing what is your value add
pre-framing so part of what
uh you need to
we would we wouldn't need to look at
this yet okay part of what you need to
do when you're going into a situation
where
you think that there might be a
negotiation
for your job is first of all set it up
long before
the negotiation even happens meaning
be friendly be friendly not just to the
hiring manager that you are
speaking with but also to the hr person
you don't know where the um
your ally is going to be in this process
and to develop
an ally in this process can be very
advantageous and i want to give you an
example
um so i know somebody who uh they
wanted this job they were
not offered what they wanted for the job
in fact it was
much lower than what they expected
coming from their other job
and they got along very well with the
hiring manager
and then talking to the hr person
realized oh my gosh we're so far off
um we're so far off
i can't negotiate this with her because
it's so far off and she doesn't have the
ability
to come up to the numbers that i'm
looking at
so anyway so rather than just say okay
that's the end of it basically i want
five thousand and they're only offering
me a thousand
whatever whatever the case was exactly
um he went to the hr manager
and an hr excuse me the hiring manager
and
talked to him about an alternative
option
which was for them to hire him
as a consultant for six months which is
falls into a different
budget group okay um and
to do the work with certain parameters
you know in certain expectations of what
he was going to achieve during that time
period
which he had a good sense of already
because he had already gone through the
whole hiring process
and to pay out of this other budget
for him as a consultant with the idea
that
if he does really well in those six
months that then they will be able to
you know figure out how to pay him
basically what he's worth
um on a full-time basis and um
and and evolve himself into that anyway
he was able to do that
so the win-win
sort of situation he went back with was
okay yeah i get you don't have what it
is that i need
right now in this way but you know the
point of it is
i think i can bring value to you i think
that
i can i can help you with these problems
in particular
and this is how i'd like to propose to
do it
and maybe you paying me as a consultant
in this way at this rate
um may make that possible so
this is um uh
this is this is a strategy i just want
to like throw out to you
that um starts to get to
you know everything is negotiable on
some level if you can be clever enough
and if you're the right match
there should be ways that you can come
to terms um
and sometimes you got to think out of
the box on how to do that
so one one thing i wanted to throw out
here and i would love for people to
to add things to this as well um
what's on the board here the
presentation board here
are ideas of things that you might want
to negotiate that are not just about
money
okay um help pay repaying student loans
that's a possibility
could come out of a different part of
their budget could make a really big
difference to you
money to go to grad school or
professional development these are also
things that
if they are not coming with exactly the
money you want or maybe they are
but these may be things that are
meaningful to you that you could also
negotiate
that for them um
comes out of a different part of their
budget basically um
assistance with commuting costs this
could be something that is shared by
by you know a group as well
um so may not be may not be something
individual to you
um community service uh
writing in the contract a severance
package that maybe
gives you a more of a sense of security
that way
you know one of the things about
vacation days is a lot of companies now
are uh saying it's unlimited vacation
days you just take what you want but
just don't screw us over
basically by taking too much um as long
as you get your work done
and that's something that you know maybe
something you still want to say
hey this is what i want to do i want to
take off these two weeks
during this part of the year um and it
may be something that you want to
put into the contract who knows or it
may be that you want to talk about how
in your last job you know you've reached
the level where you get four weeks of
vacation a year
you would like to have that level in
this job as well
and the justification for it then is
that you've you've had it before and
you'd like them to reach that same level
um so there are different ways of
positioning that
flexible hours different maybe you
really like working in the morning
i know my brother who works for the
government and
they they have the weirdest hours if you
show up at three in the morning and you
want to start working from three in the
morning till
till nine or ten or whatever it is it's
fine
and it's totally flexible hours as long
as the work is done
you can do it whenever you want to do it
signing bonuses that can be a big thing
that amortized
over time can make a big difference and
potentially is coming from a different
part of their budget
it's also something to think about um
when you're negotiating that if you
think
that they are not at the level that they
need to be and one of the excuses that
they give
is well we're paying everybody else five
dollars
we need to pay you five dollars
this is one potential win-win situation
around that it's like i understand that
you need to do
parity that we all need to be at the
same level in that way
however as far as my goals are what what
my expectations
are i i
need to be at x level uh perhaps a
sign-on bonus
is something that could make that up uh
that way it's not creating disharmony
basically between the groups
so something to think about if you're in
sales a higher commission rate would be
something you could negotiate
working from home well we all get to do
that now so
that may be something you want to do
permanently that may be something you've
really gotten used to
or maybe it's something you want to
ensure that you can do two or three
times a week
um relocation expenses can be a huge
thing
travel grades i worked with a woman a
while ago now who
it was extremely important for her she
had to travel
a lot that she go business or first
class
and when we were talking about the
negotiation between a couple of
companies that she was she was balancing
out that was actually
like a sort of
you know take it or leave it with her
she's like i'm not going to travel
unless that's the case
and um you know
so they have to send me at that level
and so one of the things we talked about
is okay well if they don't agree to
sending you at that level
would they agree to giving you a certain
amount of money for you to manage
how you're traveling basically or
you know so that she could still do
business or first class but that it
wasn't negotiated
into the contract to begin with however
the monies were still available for her
to do it that was one of the tactics
that we took because
in essence this was a non-negotiable
thing for her
being able to travel business or first
class because of the length of the the
trips that she had to take
and because of her health and it just
wasn't an option
um so looking at it in different ways
it's like this is something i need okay
how are you going to get me that
you know even if your policy might say
hey we don't send anybody first class
that's fine but let's talk about just
the budget if i can manage the budget
and and pull that off
of course there's no reason why i
couldn't go first class
um if if it's it's about that managing
so anyway so i wanted to give you an
example of that as well
so in setting up a negotiation agenda
and and that is something to that you
could potentially do
whether you're getting a promotion or
you're getting a job for the first time
um these are the few things that you
should be thinking about
thanking your employer of course showing
that you're really enthusiastic that you
really want the job
okay showing them again what it is that
you're going to be bringing to the job
what we want to do is we want to set up
a a positive situation to begin with
not starting a conversation with
uh you know i wanted to take this job
you know i think you're you're okay but
but this is too low
okay we want it we want to set up first
like why did they like you to begin with
you know why do they want to work with
you to begin with what was the value
that they were hoping to get
from you reminding them of that
reminding them of your friendliness and
of your
you know willingness to work with them
and that your enthusiasm to work with
them basically
also letting them know that you you're
there
to work it out you're there to find a
win-win situation
you're not there to harangue them
you're not there to um
figure out ways that it won't happen
you're you're
you're there to try to figure out ways
that it can happen okay
so um i'll talk about a couple in number
six here
discuss resolve ways to bridge the gap
i'm going to go through some actual
dialogue on here that
will help in a moment but you know
asking questions asking about what
they're thinking was
for example okay um if if they
are offering a salary that is
let's say you know five percent less
than the
going rate salary wise in that area for
that type of position
um you might want to ask what was the
thinking
behind it there may be some thought
behind it
you phrasing it as like you know i've
done my research
and i'm seeing that you're you're
offering you know
about five percent less than the going
rate in this area for
a person of um you know three years of
experience
and in this background in software
engineering uh
can you share with me some of the
thinking behind that
so i you can get insight from them
by asking questions which might help
with your negotiation as well
they might say oh well you know we just
we we didn't know who knows um and
and now they know they could also say
that's right we're undercutting but
the thing is that we're giving a lot of
stock options and
that may be where we're trying to we're
trying to make it up and then we can
start having a conversation about stock
options and maybe that's something that
you want even more of
or that you want something else from
so the main thing that i want to get
across
as far as the negotiation agenda goes
is that you want it to be a friendly
negotiation first of all if you want it
you want to be looking at it as i want
to win
i want to work with you and you want to
win
you want to be able to be comfortable in
the salary
and the perks and the you know
everything that you're offering
um that that you're in a comfortable
place as well
so that they're not walking away
thinking oh
he really raked me over the coals here
you know
demanding every you know all these
things and and
it was it was too hard for me to to
agree to it basically or i agreed to it
and and now we're going to have to you
know have less
money for this that and the other
because we want him so badly
we're not looking for them to um
we're not looking for them to once
renege on the offer
and say okay this is not possible um and
you've turned into a
monster negotiator and this is not where
i have
the power to give you these things um
and two we don't want to um
set ourselves up to not be not
to put them into a situation where we
have to turn the the job down basically
because we've said well i won't do it
for anything less than x
and i have no um no
idea as to how to get you to x or
no thought or proposal as to how to do
that
or maybe i had no rationale whatsoever i
just number wise i wanted
x dollars there's no history of that
there's
in my history and there's no tradition
of that in the salary of the area
it's just a number that i wanted um
that's not a rationale really um
but the the key to the whole thing in
the end is trying to
figure out different options to make
things possible
and the empowerment that i want to
emphasize
is that that they did not bring up
these things doesn't mean that you
cannot bring these things up
that it was never mentioned what uh
style of travel you would want right
for example um but that's that an
important
thing to you that can be something that
you were that you bring up and that
could be put into the
the contract as well um
so in setting the agenda
whoever sets the agenda this is just a
clue anyway okay
whoever sets the agenda sets the
different things that
could be potentially on the table not
that the other person
couldn't bring things to the table as
well but you
by setting the agenda can set a lot of
the parameters there and a lot of the
possibilities
when we're talking about options does
that make sense to people
you can chime in on chat or um
or whatever you like you can also unmute
yourself
okay so
uh one thing i talked about i just
wanted to give you a list here of
places that you can go um this
are it is very important when you're
applying for a job
that you have a sense of what the market
will bear
in your particular area because
what they pay in san francisco versus
what they pay
in bangalore or what they pay in
amsterdam is different um
with the same work in involved because
it has to do with the cost of living
and and potentially the economy of the
country itself as well
so one of the things that you really
want to do is you want to know
what the going rate is if you can find
out from within the company
beforehand great and i'm always a big
believer in
um you know having an ally in the
company having a referral basically in
order to get the job to begin with
but also to give you insight financially
into like
what the expectations are but these
resources on the right side
um can
be helpful not all of them are the same
level helpful
um so glassdoor a lot of people go to
glass store and glass
glass door is more of a self-reporting
system
whereas the bureau of labor statistics
is more of a government reporting system
unfortunately that one's only useful for
the us
but there are there are other ones as
well so you
want to know your market
okay you are a product on some level
and you want to know what the market
will bear for your product
um what what people are willing to spend
in that area and that
information um can go to
you know asking why they're not at that
level that can also make you aware right
away
if they're like exceeding that level and
this angle is not one you want to
to play on basically because you don't
want to say to them
hey the going rate is five dollars you
offered me 10 but i really want 15.
okay that doesn't help with your that
doesn't create any sort of win-win
you know argument and nor does it show
that the research is able to support
your assessment that you deserve 15.
okay so i wanted to go over a couple of
ideas um
to exemplify what i'm talking about here
so in this case this is about a
salary being lower than what you
expected okay
so they the setup the setup that you do
to begin with
is i'm wondering if you might be
flexible on that salary figure the
number was slightly lower than i
expected
and after researching salary.com
wherever
or people in your organization and
talking to several peers in this area
i was expecting a range between
x and x okay now here as far as
rationale goes
you could also add in for example and
with someone
with my years worth of experience or
with the sorts of
achievements that you know value that
i've brought to companies before
i am looking for or i was expecting
excuse me
uh between you know 50 and 55 000
and i thought i would be on the upper
end of that given what i
was able to do before and then see what
they say
okay so maybe they adjust
and that's the end of it thank you very
much okay let's move on
hold on one second um or uh
or they don't which i'll get to in a
second okay but um
the what you really want to set up here
though
is that what the expectation is that you
have
what the rationale is for you to have
more than whatever it is that they
offered and then
to again be thankful and to listen and
if there is a reason
like that one i gave earlier when we
were talking um
about well i we can't you know the
unfortunate thing is we may not be
competitive with the entire you know
san francisco area however
um this is what everybody else is
getting and i can't offer you more than
that
that's when you can go to ah okay
well then maybe we can figure out
something else the sign-on bonus maybe
is a possibility
maybe you only want to do part-time work
maybe that's that's
a possibility also um i'm not sure but
then then you at least know uh if they
say no what the
what the meaning the reasons behind it
might be
okay so if the salary is not met
um this first one it goes to exactly
what i was just talking about
maintaining equity amongst the team
basically could a sign-on bonus be
possible
this is what this this option here is a
negotiation i've done
also personally in my past which is
that's fine if the salary is locked in
at this level
however i don't want to wait a year
um to get up to the level that i would
like to be
can we do the review earlier
so it's six months and setting clear
parameters as to what it is that
i'm going to be achieving during this
time in writing okay
and that they're achievable in writing
um
then then can we have the review at the
six-month level with the expectation
that we will be reaching the level that
i would like to be at
financially okay um
that's an option uh just moving that up
basically
uh this is another possibility is
if it's locked in for a certain pay
grade and
you would like to be at a higher level
and that is a different pay grade
is it possible that they could add
different responsibilities that would
allow you to be in at that pay grade
basically
um and that you feel like you could do
so the reclassification
is that possible that's for like
obviously a large organization
but might be possible um
so then and then there's a couple of
other options i've put down here as you
can see
you know car option is a possibility
i like this phrase here and and it's
something that
is an open-ended one and good to know
if the salary is much lower than
expected to ask would you be willing to
share how you arrived at this number
okay and as i said my market research
shows a little bit higher so i want to
understand
what accounts for the difference okay so
leaving
don't assume the worst um assume that
there is a rationale
in their decision making as well and
and discover that because that may give
you the opening to where it is you can
negotiate
potentially from the more knowledge you
have overall in a negotiation
the better off you are so that's why i
say the more you know the market
the better off you are the more you know
what how they run
as far as um promotions
uh how often they do it and how much
they generally give
so much the better for you to know that
and to know that
and and just to know in general that you
know
in a budget situation with a company
there are things that come from
different areas of the budget
there are things that are salary there
are things that are potentially health
care
there are things that are professional
development
there's travel there is relocation
allowance there is a bonus that is
potentially not falling into salary
necessarily either could fall into
another category within their budget
and um so everything is not coming from
the same pool
money-wise so that's something for you
to consider also so
the salary may be one thing things that
may be valuable to you
and cost them money may come from
other areas of the budget where they may
have more flexibility
and by budget i mean the whole company's
budget
okay so this is just some advice
in general with this this should not be
an
oral um acceptance you should get it in
writing
you need to so this is in a situation
where you have negotiated a
change in whatever it is their initial
offer is
fine that needs to actually be added to
the offer
the objectives of what you need to do
for example in that situation where six
months i want to have the review
just giving this as an example six
months i want to have the review as
opposed to a year
and these are the things that i should
be able to accomplish during that time
make sure they're measurable in some way
and not like
i don't think you actually did that so
that it's not open to interpretation or
any sort of controversy and that there
is a
date that is defined as to when that's
going to happen
that review and what and what you will
be getting
because of it whether it's a bonus or an
upping of your
your salary that that should be
happening by x day
so in other words anything that you
negotiate
should be very clear and should be in
writing in inquiring about candidates
previous current compensation illegal in
some states in the united states
so there's a lot of uh
legalities in the united states
especially that i'm noticing are not
in every country about
what they can ask you i was talking to a
man recently
who um said that he was asked
whether he was going to be getting
married soon and
whether that would you know distract him
from his work
and i was thinking wow that's incredibly
illegal in the united states but it's
not illegal in hong kong it turns out um
and you know how do you handle answering
that sort of question
this um asking about
how you did in your other job is never
something
that you want to answer if you can avoid
answering
that would be great whether it's
specifically
illegal samir to ask what you got
i honestly do not know the answer to
that one
i know that you can um
in applications leave it blank
potentially
or do it in you know such a manner that
what you should be putting in is is the
you know the research
rate when they ask for what compensation
you're looking for
but um i don't know the exact legality
of it and i'm not an hr person that way
uh my attitude towards it is um
that if somebody asks you
yeah what were you making at your last
job
i would actually answer more about how
these jobs are potentially different
that you you know this was a building
block but now you have all this
experience you're taking from this job
that you're giving to them
and that your expectations are that they
are going to
be in sync with the market in some
fashion and that
and this is what you would be expecting
so in a sense not answer the question
um but answer it in a way that you feel
comfortable with i hope that helps samir
i wish i knew
exactly whether that particular thing is
legal or not legal
i don't happen to know
i know there's a lot of things that are
not legal they can't ask you about
married children you know your age
um so the thing is that
there's a lot of prejudicial things in
the united states
that you can't be they can't prejudice
against you
and so therefore they can't ask about it
but how much
money you made at the last place while
on in essence that could be prejudice
against you
it's not a civil right it it doesn't
fall into the civil rights area that's
why i'm like i don't know that that's
one of them maybe somebody else on the
this
this webinar knows something more about
that but i don't
okay oh i think i just skipped over
oh no uh so a question i have
for you all is what sort of questions um
have i not answered about negotiation
that you would like to have answered
sorry i'm flipping through this a little
bit there um
as we went through what i what i had to
say for about it for now
you can write the questions in the chat
or you can unmute yourself as well
um can i ask question please of course
aladdin
yeah thank you so much uh first of all
thank you for the session it's uh
extremely helpful
i really didn't know about all this
stuff to be honest personally
um the first one is like i saw like some
links and so on so is it like possible
to share those links or is it possible
to share this pbt
uh or not and also where i find this
record
okay so the recording will come on
i think like within 48 hours i know
we're hitting some holidays here
um so definitely by next week but
but should be it within about 48 hours i
just know that
the lady who puts that together she's
going to be taking off some time this
week so
so it may be a little longer um the
uh links i will put
in the chat i believe
um you want the links to the salary
stuff right
i mean not only the salary but also like
there are some slides that it's like
quite
interesting uh like the um yeah
i i don't have a way to send that to you
but
everything will be um in the uh
the recordings area of udacity which is
on youtube
um and that should be very soon
basically
and so if you like
you can first of all i'm going to uh
copy the salary stuff into the chat for
everybody
here so you have
that i say that but it's not but
okay there's that and uh
as far as the link to where it's going
to be if you go to the
career hub uh the
the peer chat basically and you look on
the right side you can always see links
there
to the webinars basically and also to
the
um past recordings and
so this will be available in there thank
you john and thank you for joining
amazing uh just like one one more
question i'm sorry
so you um like sometimes i got i getting
i'm getting confused between
persuasion and negotiation
so from your experience what's the
difference between them actually
even though they are kinda at some point
they are
similar maybe from my experience i would
say that persuasion goes into
negotiation but
persuasion as a subset
you know within when you are negotiating
something
so negotiation is a you know you're in
the context of negotiating
you know they're offering me why i want
x etc
your persuasion however you know
actually
i would say your persuasion and your
negotiation starts from the very
beginning
in the sense that you
that example that i gave at the
beginning of the hr manager
who um the hiring manager basically
who really liked this guy and made it
possible by coming in
as a consultant versus coming in as a
full-time employee when they didn't have
the money for that
quite set up right
that worked because that hiring manager
uh was really persuaded by
the uh the candidate that
he was a great match that persuasion
really
came out there and continued through the
entire negotiation
so um so persuasion is what made that
possible the nego and persuasion was
part of the negotiation that started
from the beginning almost you know even
before they
knew that they wanted you you're setting
up what their expectations are of you
and what you'll be able to deliver to
them one thing to remember
everybody is that all
work is at the end of the day
is somebody giving you money to solve a
problem they have
that's it the more that you can
keep clear in your negotiation stance on
how you are helping them
solve their problem then
you are priceless on some level because
that's what they're hiring you for
and you want to set yourself up
negotiation wise and persuasion wise
um that you are bringing value to them
that you are helping them solve their
problems
a question from lisa how to determine
the opening bid for a salary if your
future employer asks you to start i hate
that by the way
and i generally feel like the first
person who throws out the
the number oftentimes can be the loser
okay so you want them to throw the
number first
as much as you can but lisa you're right
sometimes
um you get stuck with it and they
refuse to say so i would always
answer um a range
i would uh do the research
when you're getting a range okay that
let's say um
you see that for a software developer
that the range is
between um i don't know 50 and
60 000 for a beginning software uh
engineer in in your particular area
you know let's just do logically what's
going to be the difference between the
50 and 60
000 okay it could be educational bumps
it could be experiential bumps those are
probably the two things that i would
look for
most right and then you need to assess
yourself
okay look they're looking for somebody
with three years of experience i have
five years of experience in this
okay i should be at the upper end of
this i shouldn't be at the lower end of
this because i'm not
i'm not the beginning person i exceed
their expectations or i see the bare
minimum of the expectations here
um and therefore i would i would
position myself
more at the upper end of that so no i
would not start as the average of it
i would actually let them know how
you're thinking also so if we're saying
okay a software engineer is between 50
and 60 000
i have exceeded the amount of uh
years that they are looking for i
definitely have the educational balance
that they're looking for
um this doesn't throw me in the bottom
end of it because i'm exceeding it okay
so my assumption is between 50 and 60
000 i'm going to fall on the upper end
of this
and i'm assuming that i'm going to be
you know definitely over 58
000. something like that
so to let them know a little bit what
you're thinking is does it does that
help lisa
what what i don't want to have happen
and everybody should
keep this in mind is the reason that we
want them to throw the number first and
not you to throw the number first is
they may have already exceeded what you
wanted
and if you come in with well i've done
the research 50 to 60 000. oh my god you
were going to offer me 70
and you left that on the table that's
terrible right
so you want to you want them to set the
bar
right assuming that they they're going
to set it as low as
they want to you want to know what
they're setting it at first before you
negotiate
but in lisa's case she's saying yeah but
what if they you know
don't don't tell me at all then you've
got to go based on research and you've
got it you've got to play
the research game specific to you as
well
okay any other questions anybody has you
can uh
yourself or yeah go ahead uh
okay so it's kind of similar to what uh
ms lisa
said so like what do you feel like if i
am
associates or like i'm pretty much fresh
graduate
and how can i negotiate my salary in
this case
take into consideration almost no
experience or my experience as you said
like oh and ngos or stuff like that so
in this case
how it is gone um
i think that one
you know
let's say you're a brand new graduate
because there are two different sort of
cases in that sense a lot and you're
saying one is i have experience in a
different industry coming in
and the other is i'm a fresh graduate i
what i would position is if they are
looking for a certain type of skill set
that you know that you have utilized
let's say
in projects that you have done in
college even though you weren't
paid and had or had an internship or you
know had job experience in that way
that you are actually bringing some sort
of experience to bear
in this that's something that i would i
would use
as a negotiation tactic basically as far
as
again making clear on these are the
experiences i
i have that are going to bring value to
you in this way
i've dealt with the most crazy
people from all over the world you know
and
and figured out who out of out of pools
of thousands would be
useful to work you know in this
particular circumstance
i although this wasn't a paid thing this
was this was a volunteer situation
um that that skill
taught me so much and i'm going to bring
all that knowledge to you
don't assume that because you haven't
been paid for something
meaning that it was experiences that you
had in college or
maybe volunteer wise don't assume that
those
experiences don't bring value to a
situation as well
when i was in college we put together i
was i was part of the
the committee that put together an
umbrella organization
for the university actually that
monitored
and and empowered all of the different
volunteer groups over
in the entire university so there had
never been a
a group we created this thing called
community impact
that um uh basically was the umbrella
for all of the different
non-profit sort of actions that students
could take or partnerships that the
university had that students could
participate in
that organization we founded in
x year is still going on today um
a long time ago and that creation of the
foundations of it
that that it was strong enough that it
has survived 30 years later
um you know is part of the value
that i created um back then
right and that was not a paid experience
that was a
um you know an experience in putting
together the
the foundations of an organization that
were
strong enough to to last basically um
so i wanted to give you that example
because uh
you can take examples of things that
you've done
if you're a new graduate during school
if they go to the type of experience
that people might be
looking for um in in the jobs that
you're looking to take on
is the zoom link the same no the zoom
wind won't be the same so rokio you need
to
actually um uh rsvp
for the meeting on the 28th and that
will give you the zoom link
this zoom link is only for this meeting
aladdin did that does that help you a
little bit with that absolutely
thank you so much you're welcome
any other questions from every anybody
i have a couple of questions yes first
of
all if i have some skills which are not
in the requirement of the job
but i believe that they might be
complementary
to the job like let's say i'm a
marketing executive and i can speak
multiple languages or i know some other
frameworks but they didn't
exactly ask for it how can i leverage
these skills to get better than
average salary let's say okay so
we so the first thing to establish osama
okay
and and this is something to be careful
about too is
you want to make sure that the skills
that you are trying to position
are skills that are going to
be useful on a i don't want to say on a
daily basis but on
that they're really going to add value
okay so
one of the things that i see a lot on
people's resumes for example
is they know 15 different computer
languages
and they're applying for jobs that
really care that they know three
whatever it is whatever the numbers are
the problem with them saying yeah but i
know these 15
you know this is this is the truth you
know
okay they may or may not be valuable but
i know these 15
um is who cares you've just distracted
the whole negotiation basically if there
isn't a clear link into how this is
going to be useful for them
um so for example osama let's say that
yes you do know other languages okay and
languages you know
are not countries they're going into are
not
stakeholders that they are having
anything to do with
so the fact that you know finnish and
hungarian is lovely that you know that
however they're very focused on the
asian market and that doesn't really
bring
value there um then
it can go for that as well if however
you're like hey you're opening up the
asian market not only do i have
experience working
um in china japan and korea but i also
speak japanese and korean
and that's going to help us um
that's going to help us move forward
better in fact
i i think i could even teach people
about
more on how we negotiate with the
koreans or the japanese
and what i can i can teach you
culturally what
the rest of the country company may not
know due to my experiences
now i see that you're positioning
yourself as like this is an asset grab
and and saying hey i'm i'm bringing
something else in here
that is going to be hard to to quantify
exactly but i know is going to bring
value and let me tell you how i think it
will bring value
and um therefore i am i am looking for
a bit of a you know an experiential bump
in that sense because i'm bringing this
to you
so so what i'm trying to say osama is
first of all make sure that it really is
relevant just
knowing languages is not enough um
and make sure there really is a
connection and then share with them what
the connection is
and how you're going to see this as an
advantage and how that's adding to your
experiential background and therefore
you should be at the top of the range
versus the middle of the range of the
bottom range you know something like
that
uh okay i had another question uh put
yourself
as in the shoes of employer let's say i
have
education experience skills and uh how
much
does the salary uh like
rank in the hierarchy of the things they
are looking for
for example let's say there are a couple
of shortlisted candidates
and they have a similar
level of experience let's say education
varies
how much will the salary factor be
let's say impacting the decision of
hiring which
like so that i can let's say more focus
on whether to
undercut other people or should i just
focus on how much i can value bring the
value to the companies
instead i think the first thing is the
value okay because okay
but what they what an employer wants
is they want somebody who's gonna as i
said solve their problems right
um who's going to be a good worker for
them
and they're gambling on all of you
forget them
okay they're they're guessing osama is
he a good one
is he going to be the you know the the
guy who gives 110
and always figures out new projects to
do you know before even
anybody even asks him you know is he
going to be that guy or is he going to
be the guy
who's does the bare minimum of what's
necessary and yeah we could replace them
one day
um this was not the best of investments
i as an employer i want to hire the best
person that i can afford
really that's what i want so you need to
position yourself
if that if that's how you feel like you
are you need to position yourself as the
best person
first and then as far as you know
oh you know you can price yourself out
you know i mean
that that is true and i think that's
what you're asking for here um
russia excuse me um if they say
i do not think you're a good fit for the
company
um there may be several reasons for that
okay uh but
trust me when i say that's probably good
if they walk away
um that you probably want to be walked
away from
um because if they are already getting
cold feet
or they are already like not thinking
that you're a good match that doesn't
get
better if they then accept you and
you continue to fail in their eyes
um i think that
uh let's get that sales position
a focus for a second if you don't
negotiate and you're a salesperson
so this question has come up before with
someone i know where
they were salesperson and they didn't
negotiate and the company came back and
decided not to go forward with them
and part of the reason they decided not
to go forward with them
was because they didn't negotiate for
themselves
they didn't fight for themselves and
what the hr
person thought in the end was like
they're not willing to fight for
themselves how are they going to be a
good salesperson and fight for this
company
how am i how are we supposed to believe
that
they didn't even they didn't even say
anything
when we said this is what the salary was
so it can depend on the position
but but honestly if if a company is
coming back to you and saying hey i
don't think we're a fit
then thank you thank you for figuring
that out now and not wasting both of our
times
this this goes to rokio also that you
are
also negot you know you're also
interviewing them
and if they may not be a good fit when
you're interviewing and you can learn
that along the way also and you can walk
away
i don't see that as a bad thing
necessarily that
the good fit thing it may be that you're
a really nice person and they're all
jerks
and they realize you're a nice person
and you won't be able to stand up to the
jerks
and you don't want to be around the
jerks anyway
because you're a nice person so i
i think that's wonderful when people say
you're not
the right fit because they're making
some judgment that
may be sparing you something in life
any other questions from anybody
osama i hope that answered your question
i'm not quite sure i know i went
a little bit yeah yes it answered
i got the uh gist of it okay
i do have another question okay and
sometimes uh
when the job position offers they
put the expected salary or the salary
they are willing to pay
okay and if we start to negotiate they
will say that we already
mentioned this salary so why are you
negotiating if you apply for this
and you are willing to so how can we get
past that and uh
i know the whole uh slides like whole
presentation was about how to like get
more than what they said but in this
particular
case i actually faced this question they
said that
you saw the opening you saw the salary
so
why are you asking for more they asked
me this so how can i
let's say reply to this question yeah
so um
one of the things the thing that is like
first of all
you know again you're looking for them
to to work for you
right you're looking for them to be on
your side so
we're not wanting to set up an
antagonistic situation
hey you said you know like we want to
set it up so that
it's like yeah i saw that i saw that
you're only offering five thousand
dollars
i thought that um and this is what i'd
like to talk to you about but there
might be some flexibility
maybe not in the salary but maybe in
some of the other aspects of the job
um are you open to talking about
blah blah blah whatever else might be
interesting to you
including are you are you open to um
having a sign-on bonus because that can
make up the difference and i know that
was the
salary expectation there and that could
be acceptable if there was a sign-on
bonus maybe or if this was
a job where i was only working x hours a
week
you know something like that um and
looking for where their flexibility
might be
and the thing that might make a
difference to you
that's sort of the tactic you know i did
that once osama also where i saw the
um what they were offering
and what i did was i said okay fine
you want to pay me fifty thousand
dollars that's what you have in your
budget
great um i'm gonna do it three days a
week
that okay will that work for you we'll
still get the work done
i wanted to do it part-time for the same
amount of money basically
um but i wanted to maintain businesses
that i had on the side as well
so that was my tactic it's like fine i
accept the money but i
actually i'm going to take back time for
that because that'll enable some other
things to make up the difference for me
so osama that's an idea too yeah
thank you that was really helpful
okay we are about at time unless anybody
has
another question um i thank you
very much for joining today uh
and there is a seminar that comes on
next week on the 28th
um always good to check out in the
calendars what udacity is up to
thank you thank you thank you for asking
your questions i appreciate it very much
i hope you all have a good rest of the
year as we are down to our last week now
take care
[Music]